nice work good thanks dad  why is everyone staring at me you just  called captain holt dad he said thanks  dad what no i didn't i said thanks man  do you see me as a father figure peralta  no if anything i see you as a bother  figure cause you're always bothering me  hey  show your father some respect i didn't  call him dad no no no no jacob i take it  as a compliment it's not a big deal i  called vivian mom once and she's my  fiancee guys jump on that boyle has  psychosexual issues old news but you  calling holt daddy hey daddy is not on  the table here but you did call him dad  dude you shut up you've done nothing but  lie since you got here all right all  right i was lying about the holdup but  the dad thing that happened aha  he admitted that his alibi was a lie it  was a trap all part of my crazy  devious plan i believed you thank you  son  you want to talk about it later over a  him a catch  i'd like that